-Michael Strahan is joining us!
[ Cheers and applause ]
The number 92 in New York
is retired.
And -- That is big -- That's
big-enough news to talk about.
-Yeah.
-But then you announced
that you're going to space.
-I'm going to space, man.
-[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's right.
With Jeff Bezos' Blue Origin.
You're -- You're going to space.
-I'm going to space,
December 9th.
And I'm glad you gave me a joke
from your monologue,
actually, that you didn't use.
-I would never --
I would never use it,
but I wanted
to give it to you just --
-Yeah, you gave it to me.
I want -- Y'all mind if I read
what he was going to say?
-[ Cheers and applause ]
-Here we go.
"Now, when you google
'Strahan in space,'
you don't just get
a picture of his smile."
-[ Laughter and applause ]
-That's not bad.
That's a good joke.
-You know what?
So I googled -- I googled
"Jimmy Fallon in space."
You know what came up?
-What?
-Virgin.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-It's all good, man.
It's all good.
-Talk to me about this.
Talk to me about Blue --
How do you --
How do you team up with Bezos?
What is going on?
What does your family think?
What -- Well, let's just --
How do you team up?
-Well, it's crazy. Blue Origin.
Big Blue, the Giants.
It's just kind of a marriage
made in heaven, I guess.
But I went to the first launch.
And I watched Jeff
and his brother, Mark,
and the other crew members
go up,
and I remember
being there thinking,
"I'll never --
No way I would ever do it."
It was the most amazing thing
I've ever seen
outside of childbirth.
And it would --
made you emotional to see it
and it completely
changed my mind
about why, if I would do it,
the reasoning behind it,
why other people want to do it.
And -- And then I pretty much,
a few months later or so,
got a call saying,
"Do you want to go up?"
-Really?
-And I had expressed
to some people that,
"Hey, I would actually do that,"
after seeing it.
And apparently they heard it,
and they called me,
and I had stuck my foot too deep
in my mouth to pull it out.
-I mean, you --
What was the part
that freaked you out?
Was it the launching?
Or was it the coming --
-All of it was really --
Like, when the rocket comes
back down, it was like Ironman.
This thing comes back
and lands on the pad.
-And things come out
and legs come out,
and it's -- Yes.
-Yeah.
And then the capsule, like,
this -- You -- You're looking.
You're going, "Okay.
I'm going to see them floating."
But then they disappear.
And then you go,
"Ooh, that's really high."
-Wow.
-And I was --
I had to fly, you know,
the other day.
And I'm, like,
looking at the thing,
and it tells you
you're 43,000 feet.
And I'm going,
"Man, this is way up here.
Look at this."
Then I realize, this is nothing.
So I might wear a diaper.
-Yeah, I mean -- No. Yeah.
How do you -- But how do you --
How do you physically prepare?
How do you mentally prepare?
-Well, physically,
you go there and you train.
I think the -- the toughest
thing they say is really
just trying to get yourself
in and out of the seatbelt.
So, it's like
a five-point harness.
Bop, bop, bop, like a racecar.
-Uh-huh.
-And I'm a car guy.
So I have cars with that.
-So you know that.
-Yeah, so I'm kind of
cool with that.
I fit in the seat easily.
I was worried about that.
-Yeah.
-But I fit in the seat
pretty easily.
And just the way
it's all engineered.
And when you talk
to these astronauts
who have been a part
of this program for so long,
who have been astronauts
for 30-plus years,
who have been a part
of Blue Origin
for 10-plus, 20 years.
-Smart people.
-It's the smartest people
in the world.
They -- You feel so comfortable.
And I feel safer doing this
I think
than I do getting on a plane
to fly to L.A.
every weekend to do
my Fox football show.
-Really?
-Because there's not some,
like, guy in air-traffic control
who is stressed out, you know?
These are, like,
people who are focused
directly on that and only that.
-But are you talking
to the fellow passengers?
Are you talking --
Did you talk to William Shatner?
-I haven't talked
to William Shatner yet.
I have not talked to him yet.
I've --
I've been in communication with
the people I'm going up with.
I've talked to Jeff Bezos.
I've talked to -- had a chance
to talk to Mark Bezos about it.
And the description
of it is like --
Even the release
of the capsule from the rocket.
Like, it's really not
as dramatic as you think.
I mean, we're used to Tom Hanks
in "Apollo 13."
[ Imitating rumbling ]
It's -- It's not like --
They're like, "No."
It's like the ship
is designed to go up.
And as it's going up, it turns.
And you look out the window,
so you can just see everything.
It's really cool.
-I want to --
I want to -- I want to know.
Like, I want to talk to you
as soon as you --
'Cause, I mean, William Shatner
did it, came down and --
And everyone was expecting him
to be like, "Oh, yeah.
I'm Captain Kirk."
And blah, blah, blah.
-Uh-huh.
-He was emotional.
He couldn't talk.
And he said, "What I just saw
was, like, life and death."
-Well, I hope
that ain't the case, but...
-Okay. Maybe don't talk
to William Shatner.
-I just want to see
the life side.
-Don't talk to
William Shatner yet.
But -- But he said, like --
It was like -- It was deep.
It was like -- You saw light.
And then you go like, "Oh, yeah.
We'll go out of the atmosphere."
And then for a second,
you're just like --
Everything is just dark
and you're weightless
and you're floating.
And you're like, "What is this?"
And then you come back
to reality.
And just everything
in life becomes --
It already is precious,
as we know,
but you really think about it
and you go, "Wow."
-It gives you
a different perspective.
And I think that's what
I'm looking forward to,
to see a different perspective
on -- you know,
almost like an out-of-body
experience of looking
at planet Earth where we live
from outside of planet Earth...
-Yeah.
-...and kind of understanding
the bigger picture of --
of the planet and a bigger
picture of why we're here.
And, for me, to be on --
on "GMA" every morning,
but to be able to come in
and express that to people
from someone
that they see every morning
and to have the opportunity
to do that.
And not just someone who goes up
and they come down
and they do a thing
here and there,
but to be there every day
being able to explain this.
And so that has my curiously
piqued to do it.
-Wow. We love you, man.
Be safe and --
-I will. I'll be safe.
-We'll be watching.
-When I'm back, I'm coming here
to talk about it.
-Yeah. Michael Strahan,
everybody. We love him.
His clothing line,
"Michael Strahan,"
is available at Men's Wearhouse,
JCPenney stores nationwide,
and on MichaelStrahanBrand.com.